[Music]
well in Bonn baby can be fast on a piece
of clear up faster in Paradise last
night the show turning number one on
Twitter and it continues tonight on ABC
our ashlynn Cristo flew to the location
in Mexico where she got the secrets is
what is to come check out their video
diary we are in this adorable sweet
little sleepy sleepy ocean town of
Sayulita right outside of parts of IATA
and this is where it all happens you
guys the perfect pool on the perfect
Beach what makes it better it's a little
lover's garage across but besides last
night's surprise wedding between former
paradise errs Marcus broad and lacy
padule we're not seeing a lot of love
here first everyone's favorite crazy
bird lady Ashley s was taken away by an
ambulance with zero explanation but we
think we got the real story
I actually got sick the first week here
so I really wanted to go home the first
week oh no I think actually having that
challenging situation made me stronger
then we find out the other Ashley
everyone knows that I think everyone
says dozen yeah the one who is all drama
and allegedly a virgin maybe going all
the way this season I would like a date
which would lead to a
wait a minute
you're not a virgin and you could be
pregnant front row so here's what she
told me about all that here it went a
lot deeper and there was a lot more
emotions involved did you find love I
definitely found some intense like and
tonight the paradise crew has a message
for new girl Claire back up off my man
having had the girls already put dibs on
the guys does make it difficult for me I
really don't want to step on any toes
[Music]